it's their final chance to prove
themselves gonna prove what we believe
in yeah the last year has been a roller
coaster ride for me and for Jagger more
as well actually opening mendler then
darkness hit us both he lost his father
I lost my brother this is for them and
for us yeah Amendola exactly where we
want our food to be in that pitiful
three-star restaurant a lot of anxiety
in us I should also get it right as well
I think we'll get everything perfect
everything just needs to be much we
realized if your favorites they have a
reach free star status today that needs
to have that edge
but it's not just me they have to
impress I've invited 20 highly
distinguished guests including Carlos
present' a director of the Italian
Cultural Institute and Anna del conte
one of the most respected Italian food
writers in Britain these discerning
diners will be served both competing
dishes and every plate must be perfect
right gentlemen today's the day one of
you will be going through to the
semi-final and sadly one of you will not
be cooking again in this competition you
now got the perfect platform to show off
every plate is crucial it starts now
good luck
for the chef's there is nowhere to hide
they'll be judged purely on the quality
of their food I've challenged them to
create one dish using a classic Italian
ingredient veal and I can't wait to see
what they do is
okay first ago on a minimum for Vail
please yes chef
up until now Santino has been let down
by his front of house but his cooking's
been flawless tonight he's designed a
dish true to Sicilian roots fill it a
veal served with summer truffles layered
potatoes G roll mushrooms and a cream of
celeriac I'm gonna keep it really simple
I'm fried the veal and we're gonna serve
it with a little potato cake which has
been done with a shoulder revealed then
pop roasted braised right six hours okay
really slow
what's the sauce the sauce is gonna be a
little reduction masala wine once you've
got lots of earthiness on the dish I
wanted to give it an element of
sweetness like yeah I can I can dipping
chutney all right this is classic
Santino he's created a robust dish with
few ingredients a beautiful layered cake
with a braised veal delicious like a
braised oxtail it's a real sort of party
but amazing dish mushroom for Gerald
potato before dragon-bot Santino's now
but the focus is passion and energy into
making this a winning dish this is
absolutely everything to me there's a
lot riding on this only two men Doughboy
liquidoff okay a little bit more liquid
air that veil where the truffle is
delicious but they're cooking is you're
all the most amazing mushrooms and
Jackie was not even seasoning there's
only four things on the plate and they
have to be done perfectly and if this
new strings are under seasoned it just
destroys the whole dish you've got to
taste Giacomo yeah everything and
absolutely amazing zero yeah peeled by
hand yeah so take brilliantly and no
salt on there juggle juggle
relax yeah
you say hey yeah
his sous-chefs let him down but
Santino's remain calm and impressively
focused
it sounds like batteries